[موسيقى]
يحدوه امل في ان يجد عنقاء الزلزال في صحه
جيده حيث تقضي ايام حياتها الاولى بهذا
المشفى بعفرين رفقه ابنه جرى اول لقاء
لهما بها بعيدا عن الدمار واهوال الزلزال
سعاده تشاركها مع زوجته التي شاءت الاقدار
ان تضع هي الاخرى مولودتها تزامنا مع
الولاده العجيبه لهذه الرضيعه فقرر ان
يمنحاها اسما ويتكفل برعايتها الى جانب
ابنتهما طلب مني حموده ابني قال لي سميها
عفراء على اسم خالتي
فسمعتها عفره على اسم امها من ساعتها انه
ابوها راح وامها واخواتها ضلت هي ذكرى
البنت عندي من اهلها صارت وحده من اولادي
يعني ما راح ان شاء الله ما راح اميزها هي
من اولادي يعني وراح تكون اغلى من اولادي
ان شاء الله زاد
لا يكاد خليل يستوعبوا كيف تشبثت عفراء
بالحياه واصطدمار اودى بحياه كل افراد
عائلتها والاف عجزت اجسادهم عن مقاومه هول
زلزال لم يبقي ولم يذر برضينا الله يرحمه
وعائلته كانوا ولد عمي يعني واقرب الناس
الي وكان اكثر من اخ لالي هو وكان المقرب
لالي اكثر شيء هو فراحت عيلته كلياتها
زوجته واطفاله واخته فما ظل احدهم غير
البنت ذكرى من عنده فبدي يربيها انا وراح
تظل هاي ذكرى للابد
قصته مع عفراء تعيده الى المكان الذي قطع
فيه حبلها السريه من والدتها ونجح في
اخراجها من تحت هذه الانقاض لتصبح عنوان
امل يحفظ في ذاكره الملايين عن الكارثه
لا يتصور العقل ولا يعني شي فوق الخيال
الناس الساعه اربعه نشتغل جبنا اليات
بلشنا للساعه 2:00 لقينا الطفله هاي
تقريبا وبقدر ما لاقت قصه ولاده الرضيعه
تفاعلا واسعا شكلت بالنسبه لمنقذها خليل
منعرجا حاسما في حياته وسيكون يوم اخراجها
من المشفى ونقلها الى بيته بدايه جديده
لفصول قصه جميله اختصرت مشهد الموت
والحياه عبد القادر خربوش العربيه